our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy
what are we
what do we stand for
being a Mandalorian is not just learning
about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate
the Galaxy
that way
you'll never be lost
[Applause]
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven for my
transgressions
this is the way
there's something dangerous happening
out there and by the time it becomes big
enough for you to act
it'll be too late
[Applause]
kid
[Music]
this is the way
I don't even know why we're doing this
it's not a duet
Billy you wrote a good song not a great
one
did you guys want to record something or
fight more I'm fine either way okay
let's get this uh started this is
Honeycomb
take one
can I ask you a question
what do you think the song's about what
do I think the song is about what the
song what do I think the song that I
wrote is about
it's about starting a new life
[Music]
it's about dreaming of something
different
don't stop
I wanted to take a daisy look we don't
need to argue
I was just gonna say that I love the
sound of your voice
[Music]
your first single and it hits number one
how do you stop that
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're making an album it's an
intimate thing it has to be I've never
seen him smile this much in his life
[Applause]
I used to be the first person that could
play things for
[Music]
people want to see it's an act you know
that
[Music]
tell me that there's nothing going on
between us tell me if I'm crazy
if you love her I know who if you ever
do that is why this ends
[Music]
[Applause]
do you think it's time to add a little
fire don't overthink it I'm the fire
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
why it you know cheers with water it's
bad luck I'll be fine
I'm fine
somebody give me a damn glass of wine
Who's down to party I got a Boombox I
got peppermints I've got a ton of
cocaine
you can't reason with Noah's heart
that's what makes him so sweet damn did
you just see that you're gonna go after
no I've grown and stupid actually we're
gonna have to steal my wallet hey give
me my wallet back I texted her though
she hasn't responded yet what you said
oh no that's a thick ass bug it's not
that thick a bubble that is such a thick
bubble oh that text got ass
[Music]
you haven't had sex since you're
divorced
not that big of a deal how long you been
before 18 months oh my god do you have
no Poker Face we know you're lying like
the time Sherm came to visit with UCLA
it was real nice to meet you bro it was
nice to meet you too what the hell you
didn't like me I liked you I always
liked you you're doing it right now
stupid face always snitching on me
are you sure you see that girl back
there right here going on and on and on
about boxing you probably have a shot
I made all of that up this is a prank
there you go this is even better than I
thought it would be oh he took us he
took a shot oh we got him good I could
not have gone better we're headed back
to her place thank you Nikki
[Music]
was I supposed to leave it up there
forever I mean I will you know if you
just tell me to
hands up where I can see him
good gravy is Harriet Tubman the
inventor of the bathtub
these dumbasses enslave us
roll it
who is this it's it's mama if you're my
mother what is your last name
I'm googly Khan Amelia Earhart I am
Sigmund Freud join me for my masturbates
master class what
so call me Jesus Christ Son of God some
call him broken corny
my new book idea the Kama Sutra from
Soup To Nuts
if I'm not going slurp slurp I'm eating
soup
Judas you pissed on my feet I know you
hear me
I'm gonna blow your hands for 30 seconds
and you're just not gonna look at me
sorry I only have big pieces of silver
[Music]
we are about to embark on the biggest
campaign in the history of the World
Part Two
no I think we're supposed to get two of
every animal I got two chihuahuas two
pekingeses two pugs actually I got three
pugs don't tell God
[Music]
oh God
what ideas have you got for Shakespeare
what if we do a play but it's got music
and singing
people sing their feelings
[Music]
anyone else with a good idea
thank you
I told you once you could be great
[Music]
but you can be nobody
being nobody
[Music]
this city has suffered a devastating
loss
murderers such as these men have no
place in our civilized society
I don't think they did it the cops round
them up and Ellie's got themselves the
perfect patsies
it's worth fighting for I just worried
that what
you're not ready for another murder
trial
[Music]
s this case this thing bigger than you
how's the murder trial of the century
going now you treat those Mexican boys
better than you treat your own son Mr
Mason seems a bit
broken
I don't know how to fight this case oh I
know look you can't stop your wheels
from spinning we got this one long shot
we could take down some of the biggest
names in this city
but nobody
that's telling me the truth
[Music]
this trial is putting the city on edge I
find out you're lying I will you'll do
what we will not allow you to humiliate
a productive member of this city him or
you
order they wanted the wild west they got
it
there is no true Justice there's only
the illusion of Justice it's not Justice
that's an illusion
[Music]
it's a system
we'll have to ask for recess then we'll
need a damn good reason judge won't just
grab this one pick something up or not
your department
Fair
[Music]
do they think we're gangsters or
something
declined
you can't stay here I promise you I will
write us out of here I don't promise
just try
Sophie's back in the Free World God help
us all because I've missed you I've
shipped without me isn't it I suppose
you need money thank you take it
upstairs
[Music]
what are you working on
undercover project at a peeps show well
I will make Iris proud I've gotta hand
it to you don't die easy
so we just got out of prison for
protecting Costello we together no I'm a
classical homosexual I think you're
mental I'm mental am I you're lunatic
you're both crazy I'm only 10 you know
[Music]
I love you more than she can't grow up
in all this
say you love it put the music back on me
kind maybe this is who I'm supposed to
be
just don't take Iris away from me
it's completely normal to hate the
people you love
[Music]
would you ever lie to me yeah of course
I would
I love you
you gotta be cruel to be kind
what do you want
isn't it obvious
I want a friend
someone who shares my interests
and you tell all my secrets too
care about you
[Music]
used to walk along with me this is over
right over
[Music]
but one last thing the biggest and
greatest
cold-blooded
psycho
[Music]
do you really know what you want
Jonathan
okay of course I want you
but I can't have you we all have
something bad in us
not this bad
sweet Jonathan you have no idea do you
[Music]
know my favorite thing about those
it gives you second chances
[Music]
hi Joe
happy New Year happy new year old sucks
it's at Peace at Last to us and to
getting away with it
not
I've done the unthinkable
come across with your friends
lying to your fellow spies
treason
that's what I'm accusing you of sir
Friend or Foe
can
philby was my best friend for 30 years
he has lied to you and he has used you
when are you gonna accept that
the irony is even though you've managed
to hide your real self for all these
years I know you're all the better for
it now you're a man on the brink
you work for the Soviet intelligence
service how many times do I have to tell
you I am not a traitor
what difference do you think
men like Philippine Elias and the games
they play actually make in the world you
mean like the one you and Elliot are now
playing
the kid must be brought to heal before
it's too late
I'm trying to get me killed
Give Me One Reason why not
tonight
today just reminded me how truly magical
it is to be a mom you might be pregnant
Lois is missing how could you just leave
her life's worth my daughter's life is
at stake
isn't this what you've been training for
I can't do this kind of stuff alone
we'll find there
we are gonna get through this as a
family
season premiere Tuesday March 14th free
next day on the CW app
is
[Music]
[Applause]
You Can't Always Get What You Want
You Can't Always Get what you want
but if you try sometimes would you mind
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
just said great job
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
has created an unkillable army made of
shadow
carry them down this country Into
Darkness I have to destroy him
so good
you are a Lena starkoff we almost had on
the phone
oh you couldn't do it with one amplifier
I need the power of all three
and the Sea whip
finish what you started
here with me always
[Music]
now you're speaking my language
a nightmare if we got not so sensing
I didn't realize you were patriots
well if you die we don't get paid
[Applause]
I promised that you and I would change
the world that is never going to happen
I'll destroy the only thing you have
left
[Music]
you will not know what price it demands
until it is too late
[Applause]
are you willing to sacrifice
that which is most precious to hear
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
is the story of one terrible catastrophe
after another
I for once would love to wake up
magically in a better world
[Music]
the world's going to
get today people get their energy from
the Sun
humans have set foot on Mars
cancer has been defeated
yet for every question answered
another one appears
here's what you need to know about
global warmings it will all go to
at the end of the century we'll be dead
we'll have to miss it but we'll be
smiling in gold-plated coffee
this is not the life that I envisioned
it to be
house is on fire is incredibly easy to
negotiate
we cannot give up and go home
[Music]
go home we already are home this is our
only home
[Music]
it helps to look at climate change like
a bear
[Music]
whole planet's been wrestling with the
bear for decades
so far the Bear's been kicking our ass
what if we were able to develop
technology that would allow us to
survive maybe even Thrive you don't know
what's going to happen
it won't go the way you want
it never does
you remember
what about now
are you happy now
are we bad people
stop being angry about the past the
future is now
Miami is dangerous your mother is moving
with her sister in Chicago thought you
hated your sister it's too hot out
to hate people these days Marshall
[Music]
if I got to do her makeup I wouldn't be
able to touch her face my hands would be
saying so
[Music]
we're still Tweeting from that old ass
swim account
she is not like everybody else she knows
what we're thinking and she gives it a
name she's a goddess right
I can't stay here with you why are you
doing this to me
I had to ask you
[Music]
see them what do you think she's doing
right now
[Music]
who's your favorite artist
you're a killer bee
part of the swarm
talk about nycha you get stung
[Music]
friends those are some crazy ass fans
[Applause]
this is feeling a little bit sketchy
you know I always knew you were gonna be
something
you gotta spare in the trunk no
damn you got a dead body in there or
something
[Laughter]
[Music]
who is your favorite artists
you have to meet her one day promise me
we will
I promise
I don't know I kind of like her sister
better she seems more like you know
spiritual
Professor you barely said anything in an
hour and a half could you please just
for once say something your only novel
isn't even available your own campus
bookstore
you you're here the fact that you're
here means you show very little promise
did that sound harsh I'll smile through
the rest of this you are here at Railton
College
mediocrity's capital
I think you should just keep up with the
misery being an adult is 80 misery
this is bad they twisted my words you
know that's pretty much verbatim how did
you get like this wound stuff just well
I'm concerned that I might say something
really consistent with my
oh my God but inconsistent with a modern
college campus you lazy son that's valid
here I forgot you aren't capable of
leaving this town for reasons only fully
understood by your therapist I'm not
going my life is here you might not be
coming with me you are not here either
I've been holding on to a lot of anger
towards you
[Music]
see
come on you want a piece of this that
man is chair of the English Department
[Music]
everything was
everything's like oh funny tenure
doesn't mean you can't get smacked in
the face you let go of the notebook it
has original work in it and not if it's
yours
ah
[Music]
beautiful
delivery on 30. yeah sign in sure you
might hold none of that for me thanks
that is a ball I have just ironed it
don't move you move the buck detonates I
hear any alarms or Sirens I detonate the
phone I understand
good I'll be right back
you need to know what you're getting
into
this is not cops and robbers
the anime is everywhere but it can't be
seen so what's it gonna be
are you going to be all heroic and
difficult or are you going to be
sensible and help us save the world
data drives everything you think you're
shopping for socks but they know who
you're voting for
blimey I can trust you
you're the one who taught me not to
trust anybody
corporate Espionage is the dirty way to
get rich are you accusing me of
something
you found something big enough to make
you a Target
it's just part of the job right no one's
ever succeeded in toppling a democracy
as ours but the country Rife with anger
and Division
is a job already half done
in fact there was just too many
possibilities
I can't tell the difference between
what's real and what's not
well you're really messing this one up
John
there's definitely something bigger
going on here what have you gotten me
into
you must have absolute trust in one
another
an absolute trust in the plan
is this Gonna Hurt
[Music]
would you consider giving your father a
call would we consider at least a call
was he apologizing I mean did he ask I
mean if he were to call then I guess we
would see
I could get him to text a request for a
call I'm afraid we're gonna need to hear
that voice
he has been on my mind I'm sure we'll
iron it all out but what would happen if
you ownership was a bus stop
we'll always be good right if we're good
we're good
well that's heartening
that's that's heartening I'm heartened
by that
[Music]
me
I mean it's a tight rope walk on a
straight razor 500 foot reputational
drop
why is that making you smile that should
make you smile he looks tightrope
walking a straight razor
cannot win your dad will wash you away
this is a chess board are you tanking
the deal and every move is crucial like
Israel Palestine correct but harder and
much more important
a microphone and let your words now
here's a funky introduction to how nice
I am tell your mother tell your father
sent a telegram I'm like an Energizer no
are you okay okay what the hell is that
I don't know was that the same thing
that happened with the microwave
you tell me no God maybe your stereo is
just old with your stupid music
today we have the story that's going to
change the world yes it's in Nigeria
electricity coming out of their hands
all teenage girls mom I know some can
like aim it how does yours work
hey hey
[Applause]
but it's hundreds and thousands
I'm a journalist I want to tell your
story
it's gonna change this
what did you do the World As We Know It
may never be the same listen to me this
is pretty scary your power doesn't freak
me out you got this thing we all do
we got it because we need it
not no trouble smile for me
oh you look nice when you smile
testing everyone I have two key people
safe
invasive it's unethical I'm just asking
for a list you're gonna treat our kids
like criminals
I feel something different about
how she has done amazing things
dad let me come work for you cause I can
help but that's money
myself
I didn't even realize that I was living
in constant fear
I see the world how you see it
always made me see how well that could
be better for all of us I just feel like
a hundred pounds lighter
I'm stronger
can you imagine growing up with that
kind of freedom
[Music]
[Applause]